how did you first start working with
successful people and what were some of
the challenges you initially faced
someone told me once good work leads to
doing more good work so these projects
would lead to something else and i'
mentioned the book of Manning well I had
a shoot with Snoop and his
son and he really liked the book of
Manning and he just said to me he's like
we should do the book of Snoop Manning
and I was like dude I will do anything
with you just like you're a legend and
he mentioned that like he coaches his
son in football and wanted to do
something that's all I needed to hear
and I I don't treat celebrities
different than I would treat everyone
else I try to respect everybody I don't
treat anyone that they're anyone that
they're above me or below me on the set
I don't care if it's a production
assistant or Shaq um to me everyone's
worthy of respect so I don't look at it
any differently I know their time is
that maybe more tight um so book book of
Manning led to working with Snoop Dog on
this show called Snoop and son that was
the first project we did together and
basically it was about Snoop son was a
senior at this High School Bishop Gorman
High School in Las Vegas and he was like
a star football player and what was
great about the series is because his
son was an amateur athlete at the time
no one could get paid
and because of this like snoop's
management like they couldn't get paid
like no one around them could get paid
it it was a very strict rule with the
NCAA that doesn't exist anymore but at
the time you could lose your
eligibility so a lot of peripheral
people just kind of went away and it
became a real opportunity to just work
with Snoop and
uh in the same way like I wouldn't treat
him different than anyone else I did
push him a little bit to open up maybe
be emotional like for instance he's very
more like fathers knows best like 1950s
kind of Dad where he provides for his
family but he's not the first to give
you like hugs and and all that so I said
I'd really like to get a scene where you
tell Cordell that you love
him and I won't tell you exactly how he
phrased this but basically said that he
did not want to do it and that so and I
said you got to do it like and I said
what's the downside to doing it like I
just asked them and I said I said I said
something like if you if you do it you
won't regret it but if you don't you'll
regret it the rest of your life I said
something like that and then afterwards
he like was really appreciative that I
kind of pushed him to do that
so doing this Snoop and Sun show and I
see Lorenzo fer son is on the team
Lorenzo fertita is the owner of the UFC
at the time I'm a huge UFC fan huge uh I
love MMA love fighting and I was like I
really want to work with the UFC someday
so I say to Cordell go you should go to
a UFC fight that'd be really good for
the show would it be really good for the
show I don't know I wanted to go to a
UFC fight so Cordell went we got all
this access I got to meet Dana White
meet Lorenzo fatia
Express to them how much I'd like to
work with them one day and also Lorenzo
fertita son was on the team we mik him
up and I just gave them the footage and
I think as a father he really
appreciated that so um that led to
working with the UFC so I I'd meet
somebody and it would lead to meeting
someone else and also I think this is an
important lesson uh try to be of service
you can be of
service you don't have to have money to
do that and you can be of service to
celebrities if you celebrities are
getting asked for stuff all the time all
the time people are coming at them help
me help me do this I want to do that can
you take a selfie can you call my mom
it's just people grabbing at them I say
is there anything I can do to help you
maybe I could film something for you for
free put something together edit
something do something you do that you
you're of service and it's genuine you
don't want anything else in return um
that's a good way to form a relationship
with people that's how I met robow um
Robo was going to narrate he just wanted
to narrate and I said what do you what
else do you want to do do you have any
ideas yeah I'd really I'm like all right
let's do him I'll I'll do the work so he
started looking to me as somebody to
work on unscripted ideas with so I I
would give that advice try to be of
service
you know and that that's true not even
with celebrities but on a film set you
know if you're a production assistant
and you want to be a writer well guess
what when you're on the film set be a
good production assistant you're not a
writer at the time you're a production
assistant be of service I I've seen
people who are like begrudgingly doing
their job because they want to do be
something else
well be invaluable at whatever you're
doing and then other PE the want to keep
having you come back and then you say
hey I'm a writ you read my script they
be like yeah I'll read your script
you're great at doing being a grip so
yes I will read it and um so try to make
yourself valuable in some way you had a
quote on your Twitter that I I love here
you you tweeted it you
put this is some of the best advice I've
ever read on Twitter if you aren't
willing to look like a foolish beginner
you'll never become a graceful Master no
hm um I don't yeah I don't know what
date that was I kind of scoured your
your your Twitter for just interesting
uh tidbits and I found that and I think
you were quoting someone I don't know I
mean I try not to have too much of an
ego I'm not afraid to look foolish or or
to say I don't know but I'm willing to
find out uh I think that's important
too
and uh I think I I prep a lot on my on
my whatever I'm working on especially on
my movie I prepped a lot
but I'm also willing to say yeah we
could try that or no maybe that's not
working I I think
maybe if you think about ego a lot of
times it's insecurity comes through so
there's no like there's no one right way
to make an egg some people can scramble
them some people can keep them
hardboiled so with production uh I can
say like yeah I messed up in fact I had
a meeting this
morning that I totally forgot about and
I was at the gym and I got the
notification on my phone I was like yeah
boy so I called him up and uh I was my
instinct was to lie and I really try not
to lie at all try to be honest and I
just said I just totally screwed up and
I just completely was honest I said um
at the gym right
now did not plan accordingly I'm really
sorry I will Zoom with you or I can be
there in a half hour and the guy's like
yeah come in a half hour and then he
said to me that was really really
refreshing that you were just honest so
uh you know don't be afraid to to be
that way you know that being said if you
make a mistake you don't want to make it
twice you know it's okay to make a
mistake it's okay to apologize say
you're sorry but you don't want it to
keep happening either so it's uh there
is a balance you need to
strike